alors s'atteler à décrypter ce qui est
en train de se passer sur le terrain
avec vous bilal taha bonjour là bonjour
pour commencer rapidement la situation à
kiev pour résumer un calme précaire
alors qu'un cessez le feu a été décrété
oui tout à fait alors notre notre
correspondant nous disais à l'instant
que les rues de la ville étaient très
calmes elles sont très calmes pour une
excellente raison c'est parce que vous
venez de dire il y à un couvre-feu alors
un couvre-feu ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les citoyens n'ont pas le droit
de sortir de chez eux ou n'ont pas le
droit de sortir de leur abri alors il
faut imaginer ont quand même on parle
d'un million un million de 1 million 300
mille personnes dans des bunkers sous
terre dans les stations de métro qui
sont terrés qui attendent et qui
entendent ces explosions qui sont eux
qui sont sur la ville depuis plusieurs
jours parce que là si vous si vous
voulez on a donc toujours se feront
cette armée russe qui est venu depuis le
nord ouest et qui est bloqué en banlieue
de kiev dans les alentours dire pin et
on a depuis quelques jours cet
enroulement venus de l'est et qui est
bloqué dans la dans la banlieue est de
la capitale ça si vous voulez les
militaires russes est à dire les chars
les tanks et ses soldats ne sont pas
dans kiev en revanche la capitale elle
subi des bombardements et on se souvient
et hier mardi d'un notamment d'un
missile qui était tombé à à peine un
kilomètre de la place maïdan donc cette
place du centre de kiev qui est tombé
donc dans une zone résidentielle qui
aurait abrité un atelier de confection
du d'un complexe militaro
militaro-industriel donc effectivement
kiev et sous pression il ya quand même
si vous voulez un aspect de guerre
psychologique un là dedans c'est à dire
que jusqu'à quand pour déjà que la
moitié de la capitale des habitants de
la capitale ont fui un c'est pour ça que
je parlais de d'un million trois cent
mille personnes parce qu'en fait ils
sont plus trois millions normalement
jusqu'à temps jusqu'à quand ils vont
pouvoir survivre tout simplement sous
terre avec cette pression des des bombes
au dessus d'eux alors il ya ces sites